Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Hello Neighbor.
Now, you may be wondering...
Din--
Daad--
Wheeyy---???
ShwOoouL---?????
That was not meant as an insult.
I'm assuming you have coherent thoughts inside your head
unlike myself.
But!
There was an update to the game.
As with every update to this game they add more stuff
to the neighbor's house and they take away stuff from mine.
I cant even go IN
my own front door anymore.
That's how limited I am now.
BUT!
I just wanted to do a quick-- oookay
Hi. What are you doing?
OKAY. You were gliding for a little bit there.
You were gliding and I didn't know why
and you've got a flashlight and I don't know why...
Alright, you carry oooon....
I'm gonna do something, apparently.
Howdy-ho, neighbor.
You're- you're- you're doing lovely here..
Heeey.
Hi~!
Hello!
Hi!
Okaaayy!
Alright, uh, see ya, dude!
Watch out for traffic over there!
Where are you going?
Why?
Oh, why do I get such an uneasy feeling while I'm crawling up your backside?
Where are you going?!
Ah, just *chuckles* taking in the view!
I don't know what the fuck you're caressing over there...
What are you doing?
OHHhh
Alrighty then!
Heydly-Ho, neighbor!
Hi, good to see ya!
I'm new in the neighborhood!
You- You wanna be friends?!
Oh, WOAH WOAH
The *chuckling* fuck???
Oh, okay!
Guess I got in his face a little too much and he finally noticed me.
Alright, but anyway, there's--
There's new levels to this
and I can already see that they took out the ladder
that was connected to the second floor over there.
So, I'm going to go in here and also,
now the game runs like a potato.
I don't know if that's by design or not
*squeeaaaak* Hello~?
Squeeeakk?
Hello...?
Hi~
Anybody here?
Ooooooooh~
Yeess~
Oh, that's the same.
How do I take--? There we go.
Ooh~
Alright, I'm just assuming that everything is generally the same
so I'm going to--eugh...
That mannequin looks a little worse for wear but okay...
I'm gonna assume that everything's fine...
Ha-beh~
Uh-oh...
Er--
Can I get out?
Can I--ookayy?
Alrighty then...
Just operating on--what is that?
Hello~
*Speaking Markinese*
Is that the elevator?
Oooh...
Hi.
No. Nuh--oh noooo!
Come on!
No, you don't wanna mess with me.
Come ooon!
Whoa! Fucking hell?
There's cars that travel down here??
Yeah, yeah. See? Yeah.
You stay on your...oooh, hey!
Whoa, fuck.
AAAHH!!
I don't know where I went
but it was fun!
Alright, lemme see if the magneto is still where the magneto thinky thunky is gonna be.
Huh-eehhh!
Huh-euuhh!
There's a lot more bullshit--
Wha--whaaaaaat??
Yoouu didn't notice nothing and I don't know why you thumpy thump away...
Uh oh...
Uh oh.
Uuhh, either way, the magneto--oh!
*Glass breaking*
Nooo--'eyy!
Whoa! Hi, okay. Nevermind then!
GOODBYYEE~
*Glass breaking*
La la la--oh, fuck.
Eeuuugghh!
AAAAHH!
Yeeee....
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You better--whoaa....
You better watch out for the traffic here.
It's pretty brutal.
Alright, okay.
So, basically, it's kinda the same as it was except the magnet isn't so obviously placed.
Lemme just be a little more sneaky about this.
Oh! Bear trap. That didn't hurt.
See, what I don't understand is, like,
with all that they've done in terms of adding to the game,
they haven't added any purpose to it.
Why am I risking life and limb,
breaking into this guy's house?
Just seems a little bit unnecessary, if you ask me.
And I'm gonna try to make this stupid jump that...
I HATE.
Ooohh, there we go.
Oooh, see?
It IS the same. So, you DO need a magnet.
And there's something else in that room too.
Oh, wait, the magnet's right there??
What!?
But that doesn't make any sense!
How would you be able to get over there if you needed the magnet there
and the key is there??? *Chase music begins*
*Gasps* Why??
And how are you gonna get me? Huh!?
Loser! Huh!
Nerd!
Huuuhh! *Glass breaks*
What was that also!?
Oh, I don't know--oh, hi.
What're you gonna do? What're you gonna do, buddy?
Huh?
Eh-aahh, oohh-oohhh! Ohh, you don't know what to do.
Hey, look at my legs.
So, how in the world,
how in the wide world
are you supposed to be able to, number one:
get that magnet, right there?
Which you might be able to sneak in and get it from like,
if you were in there,
but as far as I'm know, that is the room where you need the blue key
so it's all kinda conundrum-ness, if you ask me.
Just a little bit conundrum-ness.
Awww
Oh
Oh, that's weird.
Why're those on the ceiling??
And why are they staring at me??
It's gotta be something to do with more of the base, uh, levels stuff--
is that a kid's toy?
Is that an actual lawnmower? *Thud*
I don't know what that was and I don't know where he was,
but he was nearby.
Eugh.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
So, if I leap in here-- *door creaking*
*gasps* WHOAAA, BAD TIMING ON THAT LE--
ooohh....hii....
*Chuckles*
Well, that was...weird.
Oh! Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa!
*Neighbor grunting*
duUUuH fOooOKk?
Whoa, he is in a ruunnn today.
Tonight.
Woo, boy!
Oh, boy, he's sprinting around outside.
*Neighbor gasps* AHH--EY! He's got me!
Woooh, no! How 'bout no?
How 'bout--ooohh, hi~
Oh, man. So now, I--I like--I'm really puzzled here because
You gotta be able to get up to the second floor
like, that's paramount.
You HAVE to be able to get up to the second floor, right?
Buuuuu-reh, I don't know what that powered down, but
there's gotta be some way
that does not involve me stacking a bunch of bullshit and climbing up there
because that's not what I wanna do.
It's not how I wanna spend my time.
Maybe there's some way that I could...
stack boxes herree
Uh oh. Woh-oh.
Uh oh! Uh oh! Uh oh!
Ehh! *Neighbor screams in pain*
Uhh... *imitating neighbor's screams* ahh--AHH! I know!
Ah, glue. Ah! Very sticky glue!
It's great! I love it!
But just don't do it again. *Neighbor does it again* There's my flashlight.
That I missed.
I fired and I missed. (???)
Uh. Oh no.
EEAARRRGHH!
Okay.
UUUUGGHH
Man...
Man!
*Smacks lips*
MANN!
Ugh
There's a whole--there's a-whole-nother set of secrets in here and I don't know if I have the patience to find them.
God, eh--there are new things, though.
Like that's farther up and out.
I mean, I was able to go down the street. Maybe I could go over to a neighbor's house.
Heyyy~
Hiii~
Did you know you're a--nevermind. You have an invisible force field--okay bye!
How 'bout youu?
I'm new here!
I'm an--okay...
HI. Hi, friend.
Heeeeyyy ooh...
Heeeyyy
Boopity-boopity boopity-boopity boop~!
~If you're happy and you know it~
Wha--what, I was in the roooaaad??
You rude person, you.
*Chase music* Why?
Uh oh. He's getting real sensitive around here.
Whooaa, I might as well just start a new game. Okay, I'm gonna do that.
Hee hee hee hee hee. Hahaha
That's something that added!
Oh yeah, and I--I didn't show you guys the
weird intro sequence like, *door knocking*
I don't know if this door is the sound of somone tryna get in or get out and also,
was he crying up there? On that balcony there?
I have no idea. I really don't know.
Hello, crow!
Heelloo~
Ahh~
*BANG*
Ah, fuck. *BANG*
I've already been startled by that, so don't even try it again.
And what is that, Russian?
I just don't understand!
I just wish I understood!
And then, you get a letter~
And I don't know why.
Why do you get a letter?
I don't knooowww!
So, I'm gonna sneak this. He's--
He hasn't spotted me yet and he hasn't gotten me.
So, I'm assuming that I'm gonna be able to get in here,
do all these funky dunk things
to all my own frivolity.
Whazzat??
So, as far as I know, he's going down to the end of the street
because who would think that someone would be breaking into their house, at this point?
Probably not him.
Oh!
Oooh!
Whoaa, that is not what I thought it'd be.
Ooh...
Uh oh.
Uh oh!
Uh oh, oooh....
Oh..eh? Ah.
Nothing's wrong!
Nothing is wrong!
You can't see anything behind these boxes!
Okay, so there's a green key here
and there's something in this room.
I mean, obviously it's the way to go in from outside but there's something here
so is there a green key before the blue key?
That's what I would like to know.
Whoops. Well, that's uh--
that's an example of fit--ooh...
Wait, wait....I thought...
I thought for a second there--
for like a second, that opened up.
Eeuugh, I don't know
Alright, I'm guessing that didn't work so,
there's gotta be some other way.
Uh oh...*neighbor gasps*
Hoh, wha-oh! Uh oh. Uh oh! UH OH!
WHEEEE~ WHEEE~
Oooooooohhh, nelly!!
Ooh, open! Open up. Oopen.
Open. Op--op. Why're you--
Why? Why?
WHY?
W--wha--what?
Hooo-kay! Alright,
that sucked, but okay, alright. I'll take it.
Euugh...
Ughh...
Ugh
Okay, so...
I don't know the deeper mysteries of this new version.
There may be secrets lurking in those upstairs rooms that didn't exist before
and also, what is with that weird, long....?
What is with this?
What is with all this?
Wha--is this part of his house???
What!? This doesn't make any sense. Why is this here?
Ohh, this just doesn't make any sense.
I mean, it'd be easy enough to just build a tower and try climb up that way but that's bullshit and
y--uh--vv--eh--I don't wanna do that.
I wanna do it the quote unquote "legitimate" way.
So, if you guys know where these new keys are and if there's a secret worth seeing up there,
Oh...
Let me know.
Frying pan?
Oooh, binocs~
Ooooooh~!
I've got all your secrets in my baaag~
Alright, you go live your life.
So, if you guys know the secrets to his house, or at least how to get started,
try not to spoil too much for me but let me know down in the comments below
if there's something worth seeing and pursuing
because I'm gonna have to face this house with fear and frustration in my soul and I will only go in there
if I'm willing to beat it, so
thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!